[Music]
it's his son
his only son
i need to know is responsible i killed
my son
we've deployed large amounts of time
money and effort
in the search for justice not good
enough it's got to be an inside job
you're going to have to go undercover
there's an army truck driver
we have a new addition may i introduce h
cash trucks can be dangerous
they're serious leave this to me
you work for suck my [ __ ] dick
what did you say i said
we need a different approach to us it's
not any of the usual suspects
what do you want me to do i can do it
two weeks you know what i wish you could
do in 20 years
you're going to give me a knife i need a
face
we need to understand what's yours
but seriously
when i do very grudge
if it's not a cop what is he
he's a dark [ __ ] spirit
hey you okay there
jesus i think i hurt someone this is ed
warren
here with lorraine all right let's get
started
residents of brookfield were shocked
this afternoon by the broad daylight
murder of bruno sauls
the court accepts the existence of god
every time a witness swears to tell the
truth
i think it's about time they accept the
existence of the devil
whatever was going on whatever happened
that day that was melanie
it's a witch's totem we think your
family was cursed
and that connection is still open
i'm only interested in reality
but i can see things that your people
[Music]
can't
something terrible happened here
a master satanist is not an adversary to
be taken likely
she's doing it
out to the again
lorraine you need to come back you're
saving him with everything you have
because that's what my ferry will cost
the right
[Music]
it's been two years since their
mothership arrived out of nowhere
an invasion force held bent on
destroying humanity
if it wasn't for a handful of brave men
and women
they would have succeeded
but now i fear that the worst is yet to
come
what i'm about to show you has only been
known to a handful of people
this is the weapon to set this planet up
and wipe the slate clean
this is project rainfall
is this gonna be it running
fighting repeat
oh that's not good here we go
something big is coming
[Music]
we are fighting a war 30 years in the
future
[Music]
our enemy is not human
[Music]
hey
that'll happen i'm bomb
i think
[Music]
i don't know why he came all the way up
here
there's nothing left
there are people out there
people worth saving
most people had finally given up hope
uh
oh
[Music]
elgato
that was hard to watch you uh coming
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we do not go anywhere near the surface
everything good is above the surface
walking
air the sky clouds the sun
whoa don't look at it just kidding
definitely look at it
have you ever gone to the human town
yeah
i'm kind of an expert
[Music]
my name is julia marcovaldo we underdogs
have to look out for each other
what's under the dogs
this is my dad what do you think he
kills with those anything that swims
your life is so much cooler than mine
there's a million things you think you
can't do
all you need is a chance to try
[Music]
can you still hear him nope just you
good
now hang on
[Music]
what's wrong with you stupido you do it
now just say the thing
what's wrong with you stupido
the world has a way of changing
and we changed
there are moments that separate us
but we always come back together
we heard y'all needed a little love out
here
y'all ever thought about the wild
missions we've been on we've taken out
planes
trains tanks i'm not going to think
about the submarine
[Music]
and now we got cars flying in the air
[Music]
who is he jacob is
dom's brother
been a long time dog little brother
you always say never turn your back on
family but you turned your back on
me now your little family
is in my world
go whatever's on you is you ready it's
someone else
he's got his own private army we need
help
no way if you ready
okay this is a bad time to mention this
but i don't drive
brother against brother this should be
interesting
but could you kill him
crank it all the way up get back with
the soldiers
it's good to be back we got no white
flag
we supposed to stop that hold on
that's been my entire life in your
shadow and now
you spend the rest of yours
really duct tape you acting like we on
our way to home depot
i don't wanna die
hey i gave you 10 years to live your
life
[Music]
now you see me rise and where did that
get you
he walked in my shadow
i trained you
see the most dangerous people in the
world
couldn't kill you
son it's time for you to take your place
by my side
you can't out run
how are you
[Applause]
okay hold on everybody
we make a good team
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
there's a place
for us somewhere
a place for us
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
i have been on a journey for many years
seeking good and what evil
was to be avoided they say you're a
great magician
tell me what do you make of the black
hearts
and then something spoke to me what was
it
[Music]
i believe my soul is within me again
brother
your soul is outside of you and you must
claim it
[Music]
i came from a long way but the biggest
challenge for me
was still to come
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
foreign
i love being with people it's the most
incredible thing
in the world what are you doing
oh this is nice that world may change
and evolve
but the one thing that will never change
we're all part of
one big family
[Music]
that man next to you he's your brother
that woman over there
she's your sister hire further faster
baby that's right
[Music]
we're all part of one universe that
moves
ever upward and onward to greater glory
on your left
[Applause]
avengers
[Applause]
[Applause]
is
[Applause]
i've lived a lot of lives
but i'm done running for my past
we have unfinished business who's we
[Applause]
[Music]
when you love something you fight for it
[Music]
we're the ones who change everything
[Music]
[Music]
a
yes
hello
[Music]
guys go back there keep your eyes open
you might see a whale
or a shark one day i was out on my own
one grabbed me from behind
luckily he was more of a love bite than
a real chill
[Music]
welcome to hell's reef we made it hi
shark attack
[Music]
it's got to be out there somewhere
you've got no idea where to look the
chance of finding anything is almost
zero yeah we have to try
she could still be alive
we're sticking fast
we're in the current by morning we'll be
75 case from here
get it made out not sure what about the
rescue boat
the current is running east we use it to
get to the coast
you're kidding you've got a better idea
so do you think it's gone it's still out
there
it's close
everyone get down the water
i don't want to be like them
locked in a prison if they forgot that
they're in
what person right yes
i am sensing a lack of focus
you didn't keep in touch with cindy at
all after graduation she hasn't even
crossed my mind in 15 years
i do remember cindy williams
she just vanished that was the time when
that
awful drug went round the school
i can't she could feel it something bad
happened to her
one night we were on merc what does it
do
[Music]
we got to go back we got to try to
remember what happened during that night
this is it i swear it happened
[Music]
let's just go
[Music]
it's not what we
[Music]
whatever you do just don't take it i
already took it okay
it's gonna happen to me i'll show you
all the possibilities
[Music]
right now
do you know what the most important
thing in life is
[Music]
perseverance
what do you want to know ask me
something
where am i who are you i'm a journalist
[Music]
lost my crew today why is he torturing
us he thinks we have information
do we don't know he's killing it
as soon as we talk who kill us
who are you really the guys
used to call me wildcat
you know what i see when i look at you
fear
i'm going to die any minute
you wanted to get in my head i got in
yours
[Music]
this
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
absolutely
foreign
foreign
[Music]
hi boys this is a community
one that agrees about more than it
doesn't put it on your kwanzaa tree
no
[Music]
being a good neighbor
i know it's easy to get caught up in the
fearless situation
i know it's easy to point the finger
and fear each other but can we all just
take a breath
hold off on being enemies all i'm asking
is that yet be a good neighbor
like mr rogers with guns though with
guns yes
[Music]
thank you for bidding on me in the
auction i am so flattered that somebody
your age would be a fan of my work i
don't know who the hell you are my ex
really wanted to meet you so he bit how
much 22. 2200
that's fantastic 22. it started at 20
and then it went up in 50 cent
increments
i'm a comedy writer all right guys very
funny stuff i also
write for broadway and movies why is
your face suddenly bigger than it was
before oh my god are you allergic to
seafood oh my god
she doesn't have insurance and she
really shouldn't be leaving him by
herself your daughter is going to be
fine
why do you tell the doctor that i was
your father i was a little loopy by then
are you doing anything right now no run
up some laughs come on queen smile girl
smile
marilyn monroe from the seven year rich
hmm i beat you too if i had hot subway
or blowing up mine
doctor thanks for seeing me so late
how's the writing going it's all of
these young kids in the tradition of
george carlin and richard pryor
somebody's got to talk to roger about
his inflections
come on sub peanut what is that a very
small peanut
are you doing what you talked about i
try not to vary my routine you have
medicines to help you i was backed up
for like eight days and you can always
give yourself an enema
i'm saving that for my birthday
who are they that's my family if they're
your family why do you have their names
written down
charlie you can't be alone anymore if
you ever need my help i'm here
i'm writing something and i have to
finish before my words run out
i'll take care of them may ask what your
relationship is i don't know i don't
know
let's travel just the hottest i know
[Music]
[Applause]
do you live here i'm his friend but your
dad needs you right now
i mean this young woman is full of
surprises this is no time for jokes
it's the perfect time for jokes you
funny old man
everybody needs somebody sometime
everybody needs somebody i want to have
fun
i want to laugh i want to not be scared
and i want to write the book and i want
to do all of that with you
hell yeah everybody needs somebody
sometimes
whoa huh i didn't want for this to
happen that this it didn't happen
your little frail body would not be able
to handle all these groceries i break
your back then you die
can't have it
[Music]